now on problem number 15 number 15 when
it is noon eastern standard time in New
York City it is nine a.m. pacific stand
it is nine a.m. pacific standard time in
san francisco we know that there's a
three hour difference between New York
and San Francisco a plane took off from
New York City at noon eastern standard
time so it takes off from new york city
new york city at twelve noon eastern
standard time what time is that in
pacific standard time well there three
hours back so that's also nine pacific
standard time okay a plane took off New
York City at twelve noon eastern
standard time and arrived at San
Francisco at 4pm pacific standard time
this is am and so it goes it goes to SFO
was to San Francisco where I live I live
little south of San Francisco but anyway
so goes to San Francisco and it's a what
time does it get there it says 4 p.m.
pacific standard time so 4 p.m. pacific
standard time and we know New York is
three hours ahead so that's or Eastern
Standard Time serious oh that's also 7
p.m. eastern standard time I'm an expert
at this because we I work for a hedge
fund where we all we do is we schedule a
lot of calls with company management and
they happen to normally not be in the
same time so as we are so we're pros at
scheduling calls the cost time zone so
I'm this is like second nature I'm
enjoying this problem more than most
people look back to the bomb if a second
plane left San Francisco at noon pacific
standard time so second plane left at
noon pacific center so 12 12 p.m.
pacific standard time and what is that
that's also 3 p.m. eastern standard time
and took the exact same amount of time
for the trip what was the arrival time
in what was the arrival time eastern
standard time in New York City so what
time is it in eastern standard time so
the first thing we just have to figure
out is how long does the trip take and
then do the second part so how long did
this trip take
this plane 12 it left at 12 Eastern
arrived at seven pm eastern so it took
seven hours that was easy because we
started from 12 and we went to seven
right similarly if we're going to start
leave at three p.m. eastern time because
we want to stay in eastern time because
that's our final answer has to be
eastern time if we leave at three p.m.
eastern time and take seven hours we're
going to get there at ten p.m. eastern
standard time which is choice a the
trick of this problem is really just
staying in one consistent timezone the
whole time you can stay in maybe the
eastern standard time the whole time
next problem looks like I'll have to
draw something draw this rectangle
little draw it in yellow let's say this
is a rectangle and then i'll i'll try my
best to draw some of these these circles
so we'll just look at the part that's
inside of the rectangle I'll just look
at the bottom because I don't feel like
erasing all that other stuff well this
is not perfect these points touch right
actually love you erase all that other
stuff because it looks it's distracting
so I race this trying my best to draw a
neat let me erase all of this the rest
of the circle just so it doesn't
distract you from what's already drawn
they're almost done sometimes I feel
like that that guy who paints pictures
on PBS because I spent so much time
drawing these diagrams anyway what's his
name Bob ok so let's see it's a i was
using yellow let me fill that in a
little bit ok and what are the points
that they draw they say that this is
point that's point Q point P point t
point our point
s in rectangle PQRS PQRS above arcs
cutie RX cutie and RT r quarter circles
with centers at pns okay so these are
quarter circles and centers of PS if the
radius of each circle is one so you know
the radius is 1 so this is one right
because this is a radius this is the
radius of the circle this distance is
also one what is the area of the shaded
region so all I have to do is we have so
the shaded region they drew the shaded
region is this that's the shaded region
they did so to figure that out we have
to figure out the area of the larger
rectangle and then subtract out the
areas of these quarter circles so what's
the area of the larger rectangle well we
know its base right because this this
distance is one this distance this one
and we know in general that these rate
this radius is 1 this distance is one
and also this distance is one so the
entire rectangle is to buy one right
this is 11 plus 1 is to 2 by 1 so the
area of rectangle I'll call that area
sub R is equal to two x 1 to x 1 which
is equal to 2 now we just have to figure
out the area of these quarter circles so
if I had a whole circle with radius 1
what would its area be so it would be
areas PI R squared and if the radius is
one area would be is equal to well pi
times one squared is just pi right pi x
1 so the area would be pi for a full
circle right but so the area for a
quarter circle so just you know let me I
could do it in this column see I could
do it in the area of that blue right
there that will be the area of that blue
area of blue would be PI over 4 right
because it's a quarter circle this is PI
over 4 and some way this would also this
work that would also be another PI over
4 so the area of the shaded area would
be their area of the rectangle which is
to that you probably can't even see that
blue the area of the of the rectangle is
2 minus the area of each of these
quarter circles minus PI over 4 minus PI
over 4 and
so this would be 2 minus PI over 2 I
think right pi over 2 minus PI over 2
which is choice B next problem because
I'm more drawing for me okay so they
grew they drew this graph and i guess i
will draw it too because the whole point
of what I'm doing is trying to explain
to you how to draw these do not draw
these problems how to do these problems
draw my axes x and y and then the graph
comes in like this then it dips down
like this then it goes up like this and
they give us a couple of points on the
graph they say that they say that this
is the point here this is 0 comma 1 they
they say that this point right there is
1 comma 0 and they say the graph of y
equals f of X is shown above so this is
y is equal to f of X which of the
following graph which of the following
could be the graph of y y is equal to f
of X plus 2 so if you if you've done
this in class is this is kind of a
traditional shifting problem so what you
have to realize is in this type of when
you take X X plus 2 before when you had
you know let's say when X let's put it
this way went before when X and F of and
why let's do x and y when x was equal to
0 Y was equal to 1 right and when we x
is equal to 1 y is equal to 0 now what
happens when x and y I want to I still
want to input 0 into f of X right I
still want to input 0 into f of X
because F of 0 is going to be the same
thing but if i want to put 0 into f of X
i have to put a negative 2 in here right
now when X is equal to negative 2 then
this expression here becomes zero right
f of negative two plus two is equal to 0
so that that's equal to the old f of 0
so then that equals one and if I wanted
a one here I would have to put a minus 1
in for X right think about it if I take
a minus one and I input it into this
expression then i get f of 1 right if I
f of if I take if I FF if I put minus 1
my phone is ringing and it's slightly
distracting but anyway focus only have
30 seconds left but f of minus 1
actually let me continue this into the
next thing then let me answer my phone
I'll see